Donald Trump was caught lying again very,
very badly, very obviously, and I tell you
this because I am trying to communicate as
best I can the urgent nature of removing this
man in the fall for the betterment of all
humanity, including Americans, and really
every country on earth would benefit almost
every country anyway.
Donald Trump said Tuesday that soon we will
be testing more than five million people per
day.
Now, that would be great.
We need to be testing five million people
a day or close to it would be fantastic.
And then yesterday, Trump said, who said that?
Five million.
I never said that.
Maybe somebody said that.
I'll play the videos for you.
You be the judge, as always.
Take a look.
Are you saying you're confident you can surpass
five million tests per day?
Is that what we're going to be there very
soon?
If you look at the numbers, it could be that
we're getting very close.
I mean, I don't have the exact numbers we
would have had them.
If you ask me the same question a little while
ago, because people with these statistics
were there, we're going to be there very soon.
You're confident we can surpass five million
people per day.
We're going to be there soon.
Trump says now that's big news.
We're only testing about 200000 people a day.
We were able to go from 200000 to 5 million.
It would be fantastic.
We would be able to more quickly look at opening
up, but that would be 25 times more than we're
doing now.
So that that's really a big deal.
So that was Tuesday.
Here's Wednesday where Donald Trump says five
million a day.
I never said that word.
You get that president testing.
You said that we will very soon be testing
five million people.
Well, I don't know where.
Timeline.
Yes.
I'd like to refer to these two people because
I don't know where it came up.
Everyone kept saying, you said there'd be
five.
That was a study that came out.
Somebody came out with a study of five million
people.
Do I think we will?
I think we will.
But I never said it.
We're testing millions of people.
We're testing more people than anyone.
Any country in the world, by far by double,
by much more than double.
More than everybody else combined with testing.
But somebody started throwing around five
million.
I didn't say five million.
Somebody said five million.
I think it might have been the Harvard report.
There was a report from Harvard and they said
five million.
Well, we will be there.
But I did say it.
I bet.
Didn't say it.
But somebody came out with a report saying
five million.
It sounds like a lot.
I never said it.
I don't know where it came from.
Somebody said it.
Oh, we will be there.
But it wasn't me who said it.
Be very real with me.
I'm coming to you in the audience.
Do you think Trump is lying here or do you
think Trump's memory is gone?
Was Trump notified maybe in the 24 hours,
the intervening 24 hours by someone who said,
you know, we're not going to be testing five
million a day anytime soon?
It would be great if we were, but we're not
going to.
And so Trump decided on Wednesday, I'll just
lie and say I never said it.
Or is Donald Trump unable to remember?
Has Trump's mind really turned to mayonnaise
the way so many people around Trump have claimed
has happened in the last year or 18 months?
I don't know the answer, which is why I'm
asking you, because it's not even that Trump
sort of concedes.
We will get to 5 million a day in in the Tuesday
clip.
He says we'll look at another part of it.
Trump says we will exceed that soon.
This is earlier in the same exchange with
the reporter.
Some health experts say the U.S. needs five
million tests per day by June in order to
safely reopen.
Unveiled a plan yesterday that will increase
testing, but not by that much.
Why not?
And can you get to that bench?
Well, it will increase it and it will increase
it by much more than that in the very near
future.
We're way ahead of everyone on testing.
We're going to go beyond that, he says.
Next day, he says, I never said that.
No, never said it.
Maybe the answer is it doesn't matter whether
Trump is lying or doesn't remember, because
he's the same guy who said this, about 15
corona virus cases not very long ago.
We have a total of 15 cases.
And again, when you have 15 people and the
15 within a couple of days is going to be
down to close to zero.
That's a pretty good job we've done.
We know how that worked out.
Right.
We now have just shy of 1.1 million cases.
Trump not understanding how vaccines work
at the early stages of the virus.
And Donald Trump understand understating the
expected case numbers there by ninety nine
point nine nine eight percent.
Give him a break, guys.
He only understated the case numbers that
we were going to have by ninety nine point
nine nine eight percent.
So that's the latest there.
It's sad.
It highlights the urgency of removing this
man and.
Any opportunity that I have to talk about
testing is an opportunity I'm going to take.
So just indulge me for a moment.
Over the last week, the United States has
done on average two hundred and seventeen
thousand tests per day.
This is terrible for a country of our population
we need.
Okay.
So I'm not going to do at absolute minimum
like a month ago, we should have been doing
five hundred thousand a day.
We're about it to 20.
That would put us on a path to do a million
tests a day, and even better would be 2 million
tests a day.
Even those numbers are lower than where some
public health experts believe we need to be.
And the way to the higher testing numbers
most likely is going to be an antigen test.
An important element to understand right now,
Corona virus tests are PCR tests.
That's typically a favorite test because of
its accuracy.
But it takes a lot of resources, material
resources and personnel resources.
It's very hard to scale PCR testing to the
numbers we need.
The PCR test works by looking for evidence
of the genetic material of the virus in the
body.
Now you have a different type of test that
can be developed called an antigen test.
This is what we have for the flu right now.
And the antigen test looks for what are called
the viral surface proteins.
Antigen testing is much simpler.
You can scale it way more dramatically.
The tough part is developing the antigen test.
To start with, you need a deeper understanding
of the virus which proteins to look for.
Once you figure out how to make an antigen
test, you can develop many more tests.
One million a day, two million a day would
be practical really with an antigen test.
Then even Dr. Burke's admitted a couple weeks
ago, you're not going to test the country
of 300 million with a PCR test, which is what
we have now.
We need an antigen test.
Although Dr. Birks says many things that are
are not accurate.
She was correct about that.